a Magic Castle is an exclusive club run
by the Academy of magical arts while
only their members and guests are
allowed in founded in 1963 the Magic
Castle looms over Hollywood
[Music]
it's pretty hard to miss I've been
curious about the Magic Castle since I
moved here and doing research turns out
is incredibly exclusive there's really
only two ways to get in be a member
we're getting an invite for remember we
are a private club very similar to a
country club or Yacht Club we just deal
with the art of magic I got an exclusive
tour of the castle which in addition to
the many bars magic theatres and full
dining area it also features a sans room
a library filled with decades of secret
magic tricks and even ghosts this is one
of the most exclusive clubs in Los
Angeles and they have been nice enough
to let us in early to show us all the
ins and outs of this really great place
for starters to get into this place you
have to enter through a trick bookshelf
so you say to the owl Open Sesame
we're on detainers cool magician and
Mentalist our max Goodwin was nice
enough to give us a tour this is the
main bar and at any given night from
let's say 5:00 to midnight this place is
packed with magicians and their guests
and people are here to see incredible
magic in a bunch of different showrooms
have dinner have drinks have a good time
oh did you notice everyone is dressed up
the Magic Castle has an incredibly
strict dress code I'm the kind of guy if
you see me in a suit I'm either on my
way to a funeral or courts but with the
Magic Castle they have a strict dress
code no exceptions so now we're going to
enter the close-up gallery of the Magic
Castle which is really unique theater
it's an intimate setting seats only 30
people it's a really interactive space
where you can see magic really close up
to what type of magic is best for a room
like this so I would say close-up magic
and close-up magic is defined in the
magic community as magic that breaks the
fourth wall can't put you on the spot
right now and show some folks yeah sure
of course no yes
normally if you see a magician they
would say something like pick a card
right that's the classic thing that
you're expecting I just want you to name
no way I'm already like know what's
gonna happen
Jaka spits okay and why don't you hold
out a hand pull them up perfect so we
will use something like alright we have
a queen here you know that's okay
we're getting there start over accreted
I'm to hold out your hand like this let
me said jack of spades okay jack of
spades alright so obviously you could
have said something like a three right
watch this
that's it what's it get what the hell
will we be able to see how you did that
I'm because you just filmed that like if
we go back we'll see like what can I do
what you can't
no I'm just saying we filmed it so like
if I'm watching the video do you want to
name one any Courtney like 52 cards you
remember the cards yeah I do remember
come up with like queen of jacks or
something
okay okay I'll go the eight of Hearts
eight of Hearts and did you feel like
that was a free choice or did I kind of
make you say that you didn't make myself
I'm working hard to pick a card that I
don't think you think I'm thinking oh
okay so maybe I was some reverse
psychology though that's eight of Hearts
eight of Hearts yeah so the reason I'm
asking is that the eight of Hearts is
the one card I always leave in the box
[Laughter]
don't worry it wears off in like a week
or so and I feel comfortable being with
his weird like like later he's just
gonna be like he's gonna like my watch
is gonna appear in his wrist or
something like I'm I know off for the
rest of this thing next we went to one
of my favorite rooms in the castle the
Harry Houdini seance chamber Houdini was
the best he really defined what magic is
today and this was back in the 20s he
passed away on October 31st 1926 and
he's still known as the greatest
magician of all
back there we've got one of the trunks
that he would escape out of foodini was
obsessed with Sansa's attempting to
reach his mother in the afterlife we do
the Houdini seance experience inside
that room it is our only private dining
space that we have here at the castle it
is a very sacred room a coveted room so
to speak when Houdini was famous there
was a couple other magicians who were
dueling at the time one of whom was
Dante and Houdini and Dante had a big
rivalry almost like a Hollywood rivalry
with a absolutely hated each other and
so we have another room here at the
castle part of the dining area that's
called the Dante room right so when
there was a fire here maybe six or seven
years ago parts of the castle were
absolutely destroyed or not destroyed
but we're damaged that was the Dante
room this room though the Houdini seance
room was completely spared and what's
really interesting is that Houdini died
on Halloween right and the fire happened
on Halloween so some people speculate
that maybe the ghosts or I don't know
somebody involved in Houdini's past may
have spared
Houdini's room and just to spite Dante
said yeah let's let a little area down
quick epilogue after this we went to the
Dante room and I had a little fun at his
expense
anyway later that night we had dinner in
the Dante room and it was great I got a
little bit carried away and when the
bill came it was like 250 bucks I was
like Dante was staring down at me as if
to say who looks like the jerk now this
video is a little too anti Dante and I
feel bad dude yeah who knows maybe he'll
end up doing something to you yeah
the castle has several bucks my favorite
is the owl bar name so for the
fortune-telling owl perched above our
committees will answer questions of both
members and guests at any time
[Music]
guests of the Magic Castle have several
magic shows to choose from and they go
pretty much all night small rooms big
rooms magic at the bar you're pretty
much surrounded by amazing magic all
night the most secretive part of the
Magic Castle
is their library of magic which of
course I was not let in sorry we have
books in our library demon back to 1786
that show exactly how magic is done that
library is probably the best magic
library in the world the library is the
one area that we'd like to continue to
think of as sacred ground and this is
the library right let's give a shot no I
think when you come here and you are
amazed by our professionals that we have
in here on a week-to-week basis it takes
you back to that first magic trick that
you saw at whatever age it was it was
that sense of bewilderment and I think
in today's world in today's society we
need a little bit more of that
[Music]